. Now, we do have some good news today. The
Biden Electoral College vote as of this moment
is underway. It's December 14th. This was the
day many Trump said would be the deadline by
which this would be completely overturned and
today's votes wouldn't happen. But electors have
started casting their votes for president around
the country. There is no doubt about the winner.
Joe Biden today will officially be the president
elect. Now, remember all of these right wingers
who said the media doesn't decide who's president
elect? Well, today, the electors will decide who
is president elect and Joe Biden will officially
be president elect. Now, in terms of how it's all
going to happen, each state is doing this on their
own schedule. I think the first states started
late morning Eastern time. California doesn't vote
until 5:00 p.m. Eastern. And at a certain point,
Joe Biden will go over the threshold of
two hundred and seventy electoral votes.
Will this be the end of hearing about these
nonsense claims and theories and bombshells
that are going to interrupt everything from Trump?
It will not. The focus today will move, I believe,
to January 6th. January 6th is when there is a big
session of of Congress where the vice president,
Mike Pence, will be presiding over the formal
counting of these electoral votes. And we are
certain. Expecting shenanigans between now and
then and also even conceivably, I mean, listen,
if you think back to the year 2000, the year 2000,
Al Gore as the vice president had to preside over
the counting when it all came down in an election,
he was in to that recount that was stopped in
Florida. And there were people who stood up and
said, I object to this. I object to that. I would
imagine that when we have ignorants weaponized to
the degree that it's been weaponized over the last
four or five weeks, five weeks since the election,
we are going to see some crazy things on December
six. We may even see some today at at the state
level. But I'm sorry, January 6th will be a day on
which we will be seeing some really, really wacky
stuff. But that is today. And this will be I mean,
listen, we've been saying it's over for a
while. Can we say it's extra over after today?
And then after the count is done today, Joe Biden,
formally as president elect of the United States,
will be addressing the nation reportedly around
8:00 p.m. Eastern tonight. I will have coverage
live on YouTube, Twitter and Facebook tonight,
starting shortly before 8:00 p.m. on the East,
5:00 p.m. in the west of Joe Biden's first
address to the nation, officially now officially
as president elect. And I do predict it will
feel a little bit different than it did when
on that Saturday, shortly after the election, Joe
Biden addressed the nation. This is certainly more
official and we will be together starting shortly
before 8:00 p.m. Eastern tonight. See you then.